[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in greetings from
california we're coming to you live this
evening from the Nixon Library in Yorba
Linda outside Los Angeles well see if
you remember hearing this story at any
point before a caravan of impoverished
migrants is now making its way up from
Central America through Mexico their
plan is to present themselves at our
southern border and demand entry into
our country with all the benefits of
course that that entails the White House
has vowed to stop this caravan using the
Armed Forces if necessary but it keeps
coming have you heard something like
that before
well in fact you have something very
similar happened is too few months ago
we watched another migrant caravan snake
its way up from Central America it
finally arrived and then the news
coverage essentially stopped but what
happened next well here's what happened
next
hundreds of those people in that caravan
are still here in the US and if recent
history is any guide at all very few of
them will ever leave once you reach this
country and claim asylum you're usually
home free our media don't often cover
that but the rest of the world is
watching and knows it very well and
that's why they keep coming the most
recent estimates suggest that a caravans
worth of uninvited migrants arrives at
our border every few days why is this
happening because an entire political
party is inviting it and encouraging it
they believe unchecked immigration will
strengthen their hold on power they're
perfectly aware that you don't like this
but they don't care
just yesterday Nancy Pelosi said it
would be quote immoral to build a wall
that might stop poor people from
flooding into this country watch we have
to do something
other than building a wall which you
can't drives very well in my view is
immoral expensive ineffective and not
something that people
country did you catch that securing the
border is just quote not something
people do not something decent people do
anyway bigots do it so tomorrow
reprobates and anyone else who derives
pleasure from cruelty as MSNBC explained
just today borders are a lot like
slavery or the Trail of Tears watch this
is a moral outrage that harkens to the
worst excesses in the history of the
country to the separation of families at
the slave auction blocks yes to the
separation of Native American families
they're morally outraged well they're
always morally outraged and the point of
their moral outrage is pretty clear
America has no right to decide who lives
within its borders Americans lack the
moral standing to make that decision we
are too sinful illegal immigrants come
here because we deserve it we meddled in
their wars in the 1980s we had the gall
to get addicted to the drugs they send
us we wants that segregation in the
American stuff whatever the point is
this is a fallen country 22 million
illegals within our borders is just the
beginning of our penance Latin America
is listening to all of this and they are
getting the message and that's why
they're on their way last fiscal year
ninety-four thousand families from
Honduras Guatemala and El Salvador were
detained at the US border not one of
these people had a right to come in but
they were not deported almost 100
percent of them are still here and most
will never leave we are powerless in the
face of this Congress could fix it but
Congress refuses to fix it the system is
broken by design voters know this of
course it's one of the main reasons they
voted for Donald Trump two years ago
they don't hate immigrants obviously but
they do believe America has a right to
decide which immigrants to admit all
countries have that right don't they
that would be an interesting debate the
Democratic Party and their lackeys in
the media don't want to have that debate
because they know they would lose so
instead they try to bully the population
into silence the GOP argument on
immigration isn't one that's optimism
based
it's fear-based this is a scare tactic
right this is the president this
immigration is a scare tactic he's using
to rip up his supporters when you talk
about caravan you're talking about white
anxiety you're talking about old white
man angst and so when they bring up the
caravan that's all we need to do is to
bring up the pictures of children being
separated from their families in other
words
shut up racist you've probably heard
that before too like every day for the
last two years you hear it a lot because
it's an effective political tactic but
it only works if you fall for it you
should not fall for it most Americans
are not racists not even close they're
decent people they love their country
they want their country to continue and
they know that will not continue without
real borders